polizeibekannt drogenabhängig aggressiv
und sozial abgebrannt nach dem
doppelmord an zwei polizisten werden
neue details über die mutmaßlichen täter
bekannt wer sind die männer die eiskalt
zwei polizisten erschossen haben sollen
wir haben nachgeforscht
ein sumpf aus drogen waffen und wilderei
bild ist auf spurensuche im leben der
verdächtigen andreas johannes s legte
eine bruchlandung nach der nächsten hin
die familienbäckerei soll er in
kürzester zeit finanziell ruiniert in
die mitarbeiter mich behandelt haben er
war zu uns als chef immer sehr
unfreundlich sehr verbal
herablassend er hat uns nie wirklich als
einen verkauf angesehen sondern eher als
[ __ ]
du
[Musik]
dort
liegen gab
bei der razzia in seinem wohnhaus fand
die polizei 17 waffen dabei besaß er
keinen jagdschein die jagd soll seine
absolute leidenschaft gewesen sein als
andreas es 2004 einen anderen jäger
verletzt haben soll verlor er seine jagd
lizenz auch privat lief es bei andreas
johannes es chaotisch nach bild
information liebt er entscheidung hat
mit seiner ex vier kinder zu den
vorwürfen des schweigt er bisher doch
andreas johannes es hatte einen
mutmaßlichen mittäter der 32 jährige
florian v er wird von bekannten und
anwohnern als kaputte existenz
beschrieben wie bild von seinem anwalt
erfuhr gab florian v die wilderei
bereits zu bestreitet aber die
polizisten getötet zu haben ein
bekannter der florian fauser 2016 kennt
äußert bild gegenüber er ist blond klein
hat kaum zähne florian war
drogenabhängig nahm amphetamine
ja und was weiß man über den zweiten
verdächtigen über florian v wir haben
bei der staatsanwaltschaft saarbrücken
angefragt und erfahren florian v hat ein
großes strafregister ganz genau florian
frau wurde seit 2008 zehn dreimal
rechtskräftig zu geldstrafen verurteilt
und zwar zweimal wegen
straßenverkehrsdelikten und einmal wegen
betruges und versuchten betruges
20 21 soll er einem nachbarn mit
schlägen gedroht haben ferner wurde ein
verfahren wegen des verdachts der
gefährlichen körperverletzung
eingeleitet
ja und am ort wo die wilderei des
mutmaßlichen täters stattfand da steht
jetzt unser reporter steffen meyer
steffen was kannst du uns wenn neue
informationen geben so wilderei des
täters des mutmaßlichen täters
ja guten morgen also es kommen immer
neue details zu tage wir stehen hier
genau am eingang der siedlung in der
andreas es gewohnt hat hier hat die
polizei am montag mehrere tonnen
gefrorenes abgepacktes fleisch das zum
verkauf bereit war aus dem aus dem
anwesen getragen er soll auch das haben
die kollegen des spiegel recherchiert in
den letzten fünf monaten ungefähr 40.000
euro eingenommen haben das heißt also er
hat die sache durchaus im größeren stil
durchgezogen und wenn man sich mit den
leuten unterhält mit ermitteln und
erhält ist es so dass andreas es
sozusagen der anführer war des duos und
florian vr so der helfer ich hatte kurz
mit dem anwalt noch besprechen können
florian frau soll ungefähr zehn euro pro
tier bekommen haben
ja also er war der handlanger dieser
dieser ganzen
ganzen sachen wie geht es jetzt in
diesem fall weiter was steht in den
nächsten tagen an ja also heute abend
gibt es in kusel in der evangelischen
stadtkirche gibt es einen
gedenkgottesdienst
der auch im internet übertragen wird und
morgen wird es um 10 uhr eine denk
minute geben und einen nichtöffentlichen
gedenkgottesdienst für
angehörige für betroffene polizistin
vielen dank stefan meyer für den moment